hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar like oscillation and
stabilization of program to death ligand
one suppresses t-cell activity I am Judy
O'Rourke elaborates and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by SM bioscience
s in bioscience a sartorius company
develops and manufactures instruments
software reagents and consumables that
help researchers to remotely visualize
want to take many cellular processes
over time within the incubator
environment the inca site system is a
real-time quantitative live cell
analysis platform that enables
visualization and quantification of cell
behavior by automatically gathering and
analyzing images around the clock within
a standard laboratory incubator the
system allows researchers to make
time-lapsed fully kinetic measurements
from living cells over days and weeks
providing insight into active biological
processes in real time to learn more
visit WWF and be a science comm let's
get started this webinar has been
approved for continuing educational
credits please click on the CD button at
the bottom left corner and follow the
process to receive your credits you can
pose questions to the speaker during the
presentation while they're fresh in your
mind to do so simply type them into the
Q&A box which will open when you click
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation window questions
will be answered after the presentation
to enlarge the slide window click on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button found at the top
right of the presentation window or
import your problem by clicking on the
green Q&A button at lower left I now
present today's speaker cha Whaley PhD
an instructor in the department of
molecular and cellular oncology at the
University of Texas MD Anderson
Center in 2003 dr. Lee entered the
Graduate School of biomedical sciences
at the University of Medicine and
Dentistry of New Jersey following
graduation he began his postdoctoral
training with dr. min she hung at the
University of Texas MD Anderson and the
Anderson Cancer Center with a special
interest in studying the underlying
mechanisms of breast cancer metastasis
since he became an instructor he shifted
his research interests to study breast
cancer immunosuppression in hope of
understanding of the molecular
interaction between cancer and
infiltrated t-cells in the primary and
metastatic tumor micro-environment
dr. Lee's research interests lie in
discovering the regulatory mechanism of
mechanisms of cancer metastasis and
immune resistance in preclinical setting
on a basis of the newly identified
signaling pathways he investigated the
therapeutic potentials of natural food
compounds small molecular inhibitors and
monoclonal antibodies to reduce cancer
progression in hope of translating these
findings from basic research into
clinical uses dr. Lee will now begin his
presentation hi everyone it is my great
honor today to join today's that room
witness who shared some of our recent
studies on the PDL anka oxidation and
the cancer immunotherapy hopefully
through this presentation we will have
an idea how which has laid basic
research to the clinical use in a hope
of penisy patient ID aphasia cancer
immunotherapy has drastically reshaped
the landscape of cancer treatment since
the development of anti ctla4 antibody
in treating myeloma in 2010 today there
are over 500 clinical trials total of
nine type of monoclonal antibody
developed by a pharmaceutical company
are currently tests at the clinical site
in treating twenty type of cancer and
over 20,000 patients
so today our objective is to first
understand the new challenges of breast
cancer therapy our lab has tremendous
interest in study this type of disease
for two decades we have also like to
take this opportunity to advocate that
there is a special need for the breast
cancer patient to be continued
breast cancer research it will be
continually support because the breast
cancer mortality it wasn't like a twenty
or thirty years ago first came to was so
devastating things are develop amount
hormone therapy or target therapy the
mortality of breast cancer has
significantly reduced so now the night
five-year survival rate is over ninety
percent so indicate that in past ten
twenty years scientists do achieve a
greater other veins on treating the type
of disease however this disease still
has a lot of issue such as a recurrent
metastasis or jacket resistant so
therefore we still would like to take
this opportunity to continuously
advocate for the patient that there is a
tremendous need for federal government's
or philosophies for basic research to
focus on this type of disease and second
we would like to introduce what we have
been finding in the past three years we
focus on a guy cut elation of PDL 1 and
we translate early study to
immunotherapy strategy development so we
would also touch based on that to tell
you how we identify founders of this
important regulatory mechanism and
lastly I would like to briefly introduce
some of the new technology we developed
in the past three years in by working
with the SM bioscience we develop a
several they are the type of methodology
to try to have a
to understand our basic of science and
try to translate these researcher to
clinical use first breast cancer as I
just mentioned is not has been
tremendous treated in the past 20 years
so however American cancer cell cleanser
society still estimate data in the 2016
the new case identifying the woman there
will be 29 percent of the patient is
will be identified as breast cancer
solely suggest either
although the mortality had to imagine
will reduce for this disease however the
interval of this disease feels very high
so therefore we as a Phase II scientist
we still have a lot of room try to
improve the treatment or the quality of
the breast cancer patients one type of
breast cancer of our interest is called
triple negative breast cancer this type
of this subtype of breast cancer legs of
estrogen receptor progesterone receptor
and the human epidermal growth factor
receptor 2 because this type of disease
laid out the treatment targets such as
above-mentioned as three molecule so
therefore there is basically no
treatment for this type of disease
patient diagnosed with triple negative
usually goes through the traditional
chemotherapy unfortunately only half of
the patient can benefit from this dirty
which means another half of a triple
negative breast cancer has basically no
drug to cure so to our interesting we
found out that in the among all breast
cancer type subtype triple negative
breast cancer has the most abundant
tumor infiltrating lymphocytes this
lymphocyte pre present in the tumor
supposed to help us to against the
Kindle grows but somehow the least
these triple negative breast cancer has
the mechanism to to silence who in
activities lymphocyte inside of tumor
mass area so these also give us a hint
that in the triple negative breast
cancer if we use the immunotherapy to
reactivate a tumor seidel ring for that
activity will be a new security strategy
to enhance the triple negative syrupy
today one of the most important
immunosuppression mechanism has been
identified is completely one and the
pd-1 Signori ethicist so the next slide
showing you is a working mechanism of
this molecule so as you can see under
penile a the cartoon shows by the tumor
cell has the expressed a lot of tumor
antigen it is opposed by the unless you
see one class on a sale service and up
this presentation once the t-cell
recognized this presentation Jesus
changes there were people were coming to
a tumor area and try to eradicate
eliminate his cancer cell rapidly
however cancer cell is also very similar
they were expressed the PDL 1 under cell
surface
this expression will engage you with the
T cell and the PD one and this
engagement will will eventually shut off
the T cell activity caused immuno escape
scientists now have developed monoclonal
antibody ii specifically recognized
either PDL one under clinton sale or pd
100g sale this type of strategy will
help to make the interaction surface of
these two molecule and therefore for
luck this PD a lot in the PD one
engagement in an effort to reactivate a
t-cell activity allowing T cell to
recognize the change ourselves and then
we eliminate the suffering substance
today these type of immunotherapy has
Richard tremendous improvement focused
mostly on the melanoma Hodgkin's
lymphoma lung cancer kidney cancer and
bladder cancer and there are four drugs
that have been approved by the FDA
current area is available and there are
another five drugs that is under
clinical trial right now all hockey and
the PD aligner pd-1 signaling Texas's is
then the overall response rate of this
type of treatment is around 20 to 40
percent Kuhlman sci fi including
diarrhea joint pain autoimmune disease
having fun but those are mild and can be
managed by zero and right now there are
more and more questions such as
intrinsic and acquire resistance hyper
cost progressive disease and try to
identify new biomarkers to proceed the
response of the NYPD around PD one is a
new challenge that awareness to body so
as I mentioned earlier
triple-negative is has the insider
triple negative breast cancer there is a
lot of infiltrated a t-cell and however
things as they are still grow so they
we suspect in triple negative breast
cancers must have a some kind of the you
know suppression mechanism so one
manager of interest is PD and one this
protein is placed on the cleanser sale
and is supposed to have medicinal way 33
kilo Dalton
so either cancer biologist what we first
like to do is to more in turn to test
where it's the PD Airlines breast in the
cancer cell line so in the panel a we
can see that across breast cancer
melanoma lung cancer and the colon
cancer cell lysate we see the simple
waste and blood we try to recapitulate a
PD airline inspiration on the Western
plant and we found that this protein
expression at a molecular 33 is very
little so we have tried several ways to
enrich this expression but he was not
very success so in lifetime we actually
injured in the we notice above the
medical way 50 kilo Dalton there is a
huge abundant we sought nonspecific
expression of the PDL 1 because the
molecule way is totally wrong and it is
precise a teacher genius expression is
not a distinct pattern that we used to
display under regular waste and blood so
we didn't pay much attention lifetime
here we use an overexpression system
with this way this is poor man we did is
we aqua Condor 33 mm PDL 1 and the we
express this protein in the tonight
retails
we found out again there is no 33 killed
out and protein expression under Western
plot instead there is the 50 product
cured automatically well PD Alliance
question we made a several
Concha and they all seem to act
similarly so therefore we start to
suspect whether it is a 50 mm medical
way of the protein of the signal is
actually the PD air one to confirm this
result we did a to a station a nut ankle
that sounded endogenous PD and one and
we found out that 50 medical way kill
thousand signals was disappeared when we
reintroduce we come to the wild high PD
air one into those ER that's not on call
we found out
Malik away 50 killed out and signal was
reappear we also create another two
crisper Kate Kate night knock out of PDL
1 and we've consistently found out that
Monica wait 50,000 disappeared
so Lisa these results suggest that these
are high molecular weight of the protein
is real PDA or one signal again like an
earlier mention our lab has tremendous
interesting study triple negative breast
cancer so what does this PDL 1 expressed
in the breast cancer in this right we
also use the pen of breast cancers their
line and we group them into treatment
Schiphol negative and the triple
negative breast cancer cell 9 and if we
did a simple Western blot with EGFR and
the PD air one
EGF is highly expressing the PD triple
negative breast cancer which has been
known in the PDL why inspiration also
show very high abundant inspiration at a
modest over 850 we're at the molecular
weights 33 kilo Dalton
here in the lair arrow we don't see much
expression then we look for the
literature to see what might be the
reason coaster the molecular shift out
the PDL 1 so one can come to our my is
that the protein guy translation my
coaster cell putting but he can away
migration dramatically so protein guy
translation is attachment of sugar
moiety under protein to for the guy
called 14 he usually occur a plasma tree
at predominantly add an XT motif
understand for acknowledging X is any
amino acid and the key is droning guy
translation usually happen in the ER in
the Golgi apparatus and it is estimated
at approximately one third of of human
protein has this type of multiplication
they are either unlink holding or
sitting second translation by
incarceration conscious protein folding
localization interaction and indict
activity so next we would like to know
whether what we observed the medical web
CT of the PD air one is real is really
casted can't cut through guy castration
so in this experiment we did is a we
overexpress
different tags of the PDL 1 in this case
we have Nick tag at C terminal we had
red X at a [ __ ] amino and week we
another a tree attack at an terminal we
overexpress in this country and then
treat a cell with to minimizing to an
income I think is the type of chemical I
can block unlinked guy translation
synthesis so we found out when we
increase the concentration of Unicom I
see the molecule weight 50 of the PDL
wine started
quiz to medical wait 33 kilo Dalton so
these results address up the PDL is a
highly caffeinated 14 regarded as always
we use an overexpression system and or
group when we look at the endogenous
table so next we would like to know
where does the disk I class Edition
happen so next we do the we check the
mouse PD air one in the human PD air one
sequence we found out there are four an
XT motif consensus to the found out in
the extracellular domain of the PD air
one they are and 35 a 91 92 and 200 and
n 219 so therefore to understand which
is I involved in the fiscal a sedation
in vain we first create single mutation
on the PDF one and the Reconstruction
era see that all for single mutation has
ability to reduce the protein migration
of the PD air one so then we
continuously create double mutant and a
triple Newton PDA or one migration was
continuously reduced here we create a
following queue when we complete we will
take full guy car sedation site we found
our PD ly expression goes to medical a
33 kilo Dalton and as I show you earlier
that wild-type EDR one treated with to
meet amazing also called nong khai can
reduce to nong khai calculation for so
in this case we can see a nice
side-by-side together with our these two
molecule which we suggest that PDL line
is only can Cassiday at least four sides
we also create another 3f
Newton as it's not an XT motive and they
do not change anymore ago a shift on the
PD air one so on the left side we did a
mass spectral analysis collaborate with
the academia sinica in Taiwan we
identified this onion 35 the type and
structure of this on 35 PP 0 1 of course
we also identified the other guy can
charger and because out a space issue
and we are not going to show you here
today
since Pedialyte heidi got a plate so the
next we would like to know is whether
least pork guy constructure will apply
its interaction with PT 1 to do list
with the first to a set our in visual
binding system in this case with
overexpression flat hacker PDL 1 in the
cell and we use a flag P to pour down
Lizaveta PP L 1 and then in cube
incubate with n type so incubate with PD
1 protein in the solution and after that
we did a proton in Spellman we found out
that a wild type CD or one came in high
which pity one efficiently
however when nongak oscillator PDL 1 do
not even try with PD one to test these
hypotheses in vivo we use a ink usi
lifetime imager assistant to quantify
the dynamic change between PD airliner
PD one so the in the first picture we
show in the red color is PT 509 sales as
a nuclear IP version and then this L we
also Express the wild high PD air one
which is a classical form of the PD air
one and then we add a fluorescent
labeled PD 114 in the solution after 12
hour of time we can major that dynamical
interaction between P
one in the PD one so as you can see that
there is a huge accumulation of red
color on the sale service after 12 hours
of treatment and on the other hand in
the nong khai consider the PD once
they're back home we don't see any much
Pete green fundraisers suggest PD
airline the PD won t not inclined after
12 hour period so here we show you three
individual chrome they all act similarly
which we consistently support with our
in visual data show that this guy
construction is required for 14 for the
internship so to understand the function
of this for the guy cancellation we did
we did a t-tail kidding si so in this
moment again we use a ink usi machine to
make to mimic the dynamic interaction
the still growth of the painters they
landed in the presence of T cell so in
this case is the PT 509 UKIP call and we
add a set of has activated the T cell
incubate together for our 5 days of time
and we can see the green fluorescence
which indicate a case pastry activity I
saw a single cells start to die we were
seated reduce of the red color and also
the gain of the wings operations and
that is quantification
tells us data embedded skycar sedation
guy cuddly the PDA one cancer cell has
the ability to resist two T cell killing
whereas Nong Khai Carter data it's very
sensitive to T cell killing next we
profound in vivo in Spellman to confirm
this result by inoculate 41 pd-1 wild
type and the PDL 1 nongak as leader PDL
1 and then into the battery mouse we
found out as a 2-week subprime there is
a huge dramatically course differences
between these two calm so just
data loss on the guy translation
attenders there blows out his ability to
surprise she said I Tiki and we also did
a functional analysis try to understand
what's the difference between guy casa
de the phone and anon guy custody the
PDL 1 so in this case we do the psycho
heads on my post rest Spellman we found
out the wild type PD guy car today the
PDR one is a very stable where a non guy
custody the PD or one the car is very
short and the two this time all
indicates the same phenomenon so next we
would like to know what's the option
signaling I regulate his bike a sedation
event so far we did is we took a two
triple negative breast cancer cells PT
fight all night and the 468 cells and we
treat with the different simulator such
as EGF IGF h TT TF a few GF and the
tgf-beta
we found consistently EGF can induce PD
air one guy cancellation into triple
negative breast cancer because each UFO
is the Lycan of EGFR so we also confirm
this result by adding different type of
EGF an item and we found that as long as
each each year partying activated the PD
air one expression also increased and
the lac right panel shows you the cell
the first item it reads major the
membrane bound the PDA or one is being
upregulated by EGF ligands so lastly we
would like to use this model to conclude
our findings that EGFR has ability to
stabilize PD air one because non guy
catheter PD air one will be recognized
by the geostationary beta and thereby
recruiter penalty our CP 2d queries PD
air one protein once PD air one cake our
calculated the he will prevent the Jews
carry beta reckon recognize the PDL 1
and therefore coastal immunosuppression
activity
and lastly since our second Oni analysis
indicated EGFR is one of the key
signaling induced PD air one guy class
addition we certify that EGFR if we use
a housing kinase inhibitor to inhibit
EGFR will be able to stand regular PD
airline expression in the king's
Versailles so the here is the flow chart
that we perform this animal analysis by
treating every day of every day daily
with a generator and also every three
days which shouldn't with 100 microgram
of anti pd-1 antibody and we found out
the combination of these two authorities
we can instantly reduce a tumor growth
of the 41 mouse cells and this mouse has
increased has increased the first Mouse
survival about 20% by combining these
two Authority we also do gather the teal
analysis inside a tumor area which is GD
3 GD a positive we do gather interferon
gamma expression and consistently
combining these two Authority intensity
or medically interferon gamma secretion
and also we look at a Queen's eye ICP
found out that the tumor area that we
combine is to treatment the grain diet
ET of the tender cells can be activated
so conclusion of this the first part of
my talk is better we found PD air one
linker guy has played either for EXT
motif Jews carry beta can forcefully and
destabilize Nong Khai custody the PD air
one
incarceration can stabilize PD and one
true prevent serious case to debate her
finding to Sangha cos beta PDL 1 and the
option signaling is the EGF I can
increase the nong khai casa data for PDL
1
so if we combine a you inhibit the EGFR
signaling we are able to synthesize
things the triple negative breast cancer
cell - NYPD one serrated in the
symmetric congenic animal model test I
would like to quickly switch a gear to
show you one of the our another finding
we also incorporate a lot of methodology
using the SM bioscience inter-site
microscope and we have published another
paper in the 1000 2016 so far we found
out is that a triple negative is also
our we are also in induced chronic
inflammation so we would like to know
what's the inflammation why this
information and caused cancer
progression so we found that inside a
tumor microenvironment microalgae has
ability to secrete a tnf-alpha and these
TNF alpha will recognize kindred Co TNF
alpha receptor so in this enlarger
cartoon on the fly site the underlying
mechanism is that the TNF alpha will
activate unless karate and coaster p65
nuclear translocation and thereby hung
on the GSLV expression and we identify
that Shearson that is a novel
ubiquitination
enzyme and this enzyme will stabilize
PDL 1 and therefore
translocate induced cancer cell
immunosuppression function so in the end
we found in this study that doing in a
tumor micro micro environment the 3 cell
- immune cell microphone and the t cell
and the hardest resell interact together
in the tumor microenvironment
related to to the immuno suppression
activity next I would like to spend some
time to also discuss our recent study
that we work with the 8
Cuba pharmaceuticals we try to identify
the first entire class later antibody as
we show you earlier that a triple
negative the has very high abundant
expression of the guy costly the PDL 1
so we are wondering if we can generate
antibody against the Pacifica [ __ ]
is about the structure of the PDL one we
may generate more therapeutic impact so
in this regard what we did is we
inoculate guy calculate the PDL 1 as a
antigen into the mouse and then we
create 3000 hyperatomic home so the next
we use a full cytometry to screen those
3,000 come try to do for the antibody
that can specifically recognize guy casa
de the PDA 1 but not nongak lastly the
PDL 1 and then we use the induce i
machine should have us to further narrow
down which antibody has the ability to
in neutralize pd airline the pd one
interaction we finally narrow down to
monoclonal antibody that has the ability
so this is us like showing you that ATM
1 0 0 0 fault at the STM 1 0 antibody
these two antibody has very profound are
you fighting inhibiting
pd airline the pd 1 interaction so next
we would like to know where does these
two antibodies bind to the PDL one guy
constructure
so in this case we create 3 uh next mot
fermentation and we keep one in these
cases uncertified as a wild-type and we
keep individual guy cancel the icon
structure as a wild-type and then we did
a simple waste and blood we found out
that HTM one do a in high bar
change the Pacifica recognized on 192
and and 200 and we based on our earlier
my special analysis we already know that
there is a very unique guideline
structure appear on this one ninety two
and and two hundred which are the two
sites that can be recognized by our HTM
1ua antibody because earlier studies
show that guy translation of the her
true eyes ability to cross link the
membrane bound her to and therefore
induce cursor independent her to
internalization so this paper happens to
hypothesize better Twitter without our
antibody in hi car kappa later PDA one
antibody also has ability to cross link
a membrane-bound PD air one and
therefore induce this PD airline
inhalation and goes to the right ozone
and further gate equated in the cells so
to do this we incorporate with SM
bioscience technology and also with the
pH rotor system to do this we for
written to label our ATM 1ua antibody
with a fluorescence type and once these
are not so the theory is that when the
cells start to in uptake is antibody
this the pH value will start on the
membrane which is pH 7 drop to the pH is
4.5 inside a lysosome and this acidic
condition will have the linker region of
the antibody to get lead once this
linker region gate live you will
luminance for revelations in the
microscope so in this case we are able
to use a English I like Thai imagery
system to major for resins
references reparations and also in the
real time we can take the picture how
and where the reparations will appear so
in this case we can see in 12 hours
serial pipe when we add HTM 1:08 in hi
body into the PT 509 stable Chrome we
can see very nice revelations induced so
just data HTM 1:08 antibody can
specifically internalized into the
printerr sale and once we internalize we
can see we did a waste and flux and this
was done in the fight after five days of
treatment we can see that significantly
among of the PD one is reduced suggest
that this antibody has ability to
internalize PDL 1 and the further
equator PDL 1 so why these are
interrelation and the degradation is so
important because recently we there is a
antibody drug conjugates
technology that is available so we are
thinking whether we can take a little
Vantage to conjugate
cytotoxicity drug into the our antibody
so in this case we choose the AE as our
warhead and we conjugate in our
conjugation and average there are 4
chemo drug being conjugate on our
antibody so we test the advocacy of this
antibody in the leisure and also in vivo
we found out that only the cell has the
Skycar PD air one expression came
specifically being treated at site is in
high body this is in vivo and here when
the mice has a PD airline inspiration
there are two more close after treatment
with our ADC is dramatically reduced
so this is the 41 a tomb and Pedialyte
debacle they do not grow after which we
twister our dicot idly ADC in high body
so this result is very exciting so we
also do gather tumor micro-environment
to see data using a fluorescence ihe
sustaining too deep at the case
activated a cake pastry activity so in
this case in the red color indicator
test pastry activity when the mice
treated with die calculated and hung a
antibody we can create two medical tests
pastry like activation in the tumor
micro area we also did a site of
analysis we found that my street with
kite has data under knee antibody has
dramatically tumor cell reduction but
writer is a new sailgating psychic so
these results suggest that this antibody
can selectively selectively targeted
cancer cell but not in new sale because
as i mentioned earlier that guy
candidate on PDL one is highly abundant
in the triple negative breast cancer
cells so lastly I would like to use a
list model to summarize this part of our
study which is that EGFR is the major
signaling that can induce some sort of
guy called transference in dashing and
these Keiko transfers will further guy
candidate a PDL 1 and then that is PDA
one goes to the cell membrane if we can
create an antibody nice specifically
recognized happily the PDA one will
hability to induce this PDL 1 and 13 and
also once this
and those Ayatollah see then happen he
will go to the night or song and then
get equated once the antibody and PDL
one get acquitted the stranger cell
cytotoxicity drug will be received and
then to kill the PDL 1 hi splashing cell
and also creating a bystander effect
which will eradicate and changes they
are died do not express PDA or 1 so this
is the world queer profounder so to take
effect in reducing the eradicating
triple negative breast cancer so the
conclusion what we found throughout this
study its data translation is a very
complex structure and it's very
difficult to assess in the regular basic
research lab so in this regard I
castration is open being methylated so
based on our signaling analysis we can
design and that design a suit a strategy
and then try to isolate monoclonal
antibody I can specifically recognized I
calculate the PD air one and we first
found out that this PD air one can cause
linker membrane Bunga PDL 1 so PDL
antibody can cause link in height PDL a
molecule and therefore induce the
endocytosis after this protein and
through these endocytosis we can bear
the antibody to carry a cytotoxicity
drug and then induce a profound security
impact to press triple negative breast
cancer
lastly I would like to spend some time
to technology
my mentor cattleman Chi hung at MD
Anderson and he is world leading expert
in study breast cancer for the past 20
year also this project is collaborate
with my colleague Utterson wailing we
are contributed to this project equally
I would like to take this opportunity to
thank SD Cuba pharmaceutical they had
been provide a very very powerful
machine and also they have a research
team who helped us sort out the
methodology we are trying to develop in
the lab and lastly I would like to thank
a Mabel savvy and a Judy for their
technical support without them we'll
have this right not if they will not be
possible and I would like to thank you
for your attention thank you thank you
dr. Lee for your presentation before we
begin the question and answer session I
want to advise that a series of poll
questions will appear on your screen
during the Q&A you may select your
answers and close the poll questions by
clicking on the X in the right corner
and a quick reminder for our audience on
how to submit questions simply type them
in the Q&A box found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window dr. Lee will
answer as many questions as time permits
and the first question is can like
oscillation of PDL one be a biomarker to
predict immune therapy response yes
that's a very good question
we do have such hypothesis but we do not
have any data to conclude that yet so it
is known that patient with more PD l1 or
interfering gamma expressing their tumor
tissue their response to inner Authority
is better and most recently actually our
scientists at Johns Hopkins University
they also show that these measures
repair deficiency can accurate
predictor in high pd-1 treatment so in
life Phase two clinical trials of study
they found our 48 count out in the 41
carnal rectal cancer patients they found
out that a mismatch repair deficiency
can predict the higher the divisions of
the patient they have around 40 passing
of the response rate to NYPD one so this
is encouraging that was so to answer
your question directly that this is
certainly of interest to test the
whether our intake our Casa the PDL one
can be a non-invasive prediction marker
or serum marker to predict future
immunotherapy response yes thank you
why do you think like oscillation is so
important to humans oncology or to human
excuse me let me repeat that
why do you think like oscillation is so
important to immune oncology yes so as I
mentioned earlier that a sedation has
been Nicolay today due to the leg of the
technology so that's also one of our
primary interest we want to develop a we
want is a priority please study through
our finding on the PDL 1
we are expecting more and more new
receptor ligand interaction also require
translation and also genetic mutation
newer antigen presentation newer epitope
a presentation T cell activation
interferon gamma equation those are the
critical step that immuno oncologists
are trying to understand right now so
Chi translation is known to involving
several process of both mentioned
process so we believe that the
characterization is has been largely in
the lead in the past and we are
committed to the field of this research
and we would like to invite whoever
interested in the
field also joining us to answer
important biological question and to
help a patient in the path I thank you
given the importance of interferon-gamma
signaling pathway in PDL one expression
in PDL one PD one blockade do you know
if interferon gamma also induces PDL one
stabilization similar to that of EGF yes
this is a common question we get about
our earlier publication so we do compare
both EGF in the interferon gamma
inducing induction induced the PDI
expression as a either endogenous level
or at the tablet expression level while
both EGF and the interferon gamma can
induce significant amount of endogenous
PD Alliance pressure in the triple
integral sensitive to say the protein
stabilization was only found in the EGF
simulator tails so together this result
kind of give us a hint that there are
two distinct mechanisms one in the EGF
case the only induced protein
stabilization whereas in the case of
interferon gamma they are inducing
through the post pursued at
transportation or regulation what caused
the differences still not very clear yet
so we also have tremendous interested in
understand underlying switch mechanism
of these two signaling differences thank
you
human PDL 1 an APC may play a major role
in PDL 1 and pd1 mediated
immunosuppression do you know if PDL one
glycosylation is also observed in APC
as a matter of fact we did not try to
conclude that the suppression of the
cheetah activity is only through tumor
PDL 1 there's a lot of evidence to show
that those you know PD are also
expressing other new cell such as a
macrophage or dendritic cell it can also
dirt t-cell inhibition ability but one
thing we like to point out is that in
our system as I show you in the earlier
slide that we only focus on the cancer
cell so our system is not to address the
way how important or whether is not
important of other user we are focused
on the cancer cell so right now we
cannot exclude and we do not try to
exclude that PD airline other type of
user also involved in such a case and we
believe yes EGF may also induce immune
cell PD and want to suppress t-cell
Shirou may be similar mechanism or
instinct mechanism which we do not know
so to answer your question sure is that
is our system experimental system is not
it's not allowing us to address IP she's
question and we are still open for that
area
thank you do you know if glycosylation
also happened on other immune checkpoint
receptors yes that's important question
so as I mentioned earlier that as many
as one-third of human protein Apple
exists as a song sold out Keiko protein
either unlink holding or sealing catch
oxidation so truly study yes we focus on
the PDL one but the message we would
like to expect to deliver to people is
that there are a lot more catch a
sedation happen on the new cell receptor
we should pay attention to and we as a
matter of fact we know that p1 also has
a guy a sedation and we bleed
those the guy construction will under
self-service we
interwined to each other and then
consider the interaction become very
tight so if we can develop a way either
using repeater such as I just mentioned
maybe tki we can it wouldn't block these
chitin synthesis is also another new way
to help us to achieve reducing these PT
and one in the pdwhite interaction and
also for your information we do have
study evidence which we are the
fenestration preparation right now that
we test another 22 setup receptor ligand
interaction and we do found one subtype
of MU receptor theater calculation is
important for their interaction whereas
another subtype their interaction does
not require for the oscillation thank
you is like oscillation of PDL one the
major signal in triple negative breast
cancer is a major signal we yes but we
actually test them in many type of
disease man Aloma and accounting sir
this guy conservation is also happen in
any type of cancer of Pedialyte so but
in the triple negative case is that you
can see a very dramatic difference for
now in triple negative and the triple
native but for other disease stem cells
we can see the oxidation some say we do
not that we cannot characterize this we
still in a way we still in a process now
catalyzing what kind of some type of
cell that has the guy translation thank
you are there any other black
oscillation targets in triple negative
breast cancer
okay you are enjoying the okay we I
think there's a good question so as I
mentioned we can either use a guy called
transferase inhibitor or sugar analog or
well right now we are walking on the ER
stress inducer we are thinking a much
bigger picture that there will be more
and more inhibitor that can be developed
using this type of strategy we just
developed in the lab so we are still you
know process out looking for different
ways to try to see what can help us to
simply discuss oxidation and thereby
intense the t-cell activity thank you
what kind of antibody is used for
detection of oscillation this is a
collaboration project with a CQB
pharmaceutical so we used a
above-mentioned of Messer to identify
this first anti capacitor in high body
so it's under proprietary
protection of the antibody and if you
are interested in using this antibody we
will encourage you to communicate with a
CQB pharmaceutical to see if they are
willing to share this antibody but for
your information to deter the
translation normal sale I mean normal
antibody some of the in hi party can
recognize the translation the one we use
in our paper mostly is self signaling
antibody so if you are interested in how
we identify the gas station phone as a
data I show you you can check our
natural communication 2016 and also our
10 2016 papers and we are happy to share
our methodology or reacting or anything
just for the beta I presume
earlier in the slide the HTM 1 you
in high bodies a collaboration project
is hasty Cuba so for that antibody we
cannot share thank you
what kind of antibody is used for
detection of glycosylation I'm sorry did
I just ask you that one here here's the
next one
did you look at consolation of PDL one
in macrophages yes this is a common
question we get up on a reviewer we do
have that data in the microbes but
somehow the PD Alliance pressuring level
and the mikromasch is not a lot so if we
use that if we induce the PD Alliance
pressure in the macrophage we can see
die PDL I'm also pleased as a
fascination default Thank You
TNF alpha stabilizes PDL 1 through P 65
transcription of CSN 5 this TNF alpha
also modulate by cloth-like oscillation
of PDL 1 mmm that's a good question so
we right now we don't know this is if we
read our papers the TNF alpha stabilized
PD aligns through post translational
modification under ubiquitination so we
do not have strong evidence to link like
a sedation and the sterilization we in
that paper we have an investigator where
the TNF alpha also a fat oxidation state
has out a PDF one so we have two paper
and those two paper we haven't linked
together but that's definitely a good
question we may be in the future we are
we if we have time we'll also
investigate that possibility
thank you if your anti GP deal one
antibody
suitable for cart one cell therapy so
recently FDA has approved Novartis
Parthasarathy for a ll treatment as you
know people in the field must have known
that so the result is very
I didn't either response rate could
reach 85 percent just in one shot of the
treatment which is a very promising
result and however the price of the
treatment right now is around 1/2
million u.s. dollar or one shot of the
treatment so right now we do not have
this is a as I mention it only happened
a leukemia which is a liquid cancer so
people are trying to develop a ducati
Authority in the study tumor
so there is no Katis or T in the sorry
tumor currently available so this is
actually a good the rushing and things
we have the entire guitar today the PD
antibody and we are definitely of
anxious to know whether we can develop a
conservative in the future to target
triple negative breast cancer which is a
type of sorry tumor that is difficult to
treat it and we are working on that we
are in the early stage of developing
this the Russian thank you the next
attendee has three questions so I'll ask
them one at a time
they say hi really great job and then do
you think that your GP dl1 Monty clonal
antibody works better in T and B sorry
one second screen just jumped do you
think that your GP dl1 munch clonal
monoclonal antibody works better in
triple negative breast cancers because
these cells express high levels of pd-1
yes certainly yes that's a reason thank
you the the eyesight show earlier data
triple negative as a very distinct PDL 1
they are all highly expressed castration
goal so that's our hypothesis that's
that's the reason we want to generate
guy candidates the Pacific and hi Petey
whines hi body and we believe these cool
we haven't do you know side by side
Pompeyo is Nong Khai Khai today the PDF
intensive therapy we believe these will
provide another different rotation to
Korean and high PD of ice already thank
you the next part is could the high
level of PDL one in cancer cells they do
to the intrinsic genomic instability of
these cells yes so but as I mentioned
genomic instability codes are not
augmentation but this is difficult to
approach because guy cotton is so
complex complex so we we do feel that
the the strong link because you know
because the ability cause like I
construct or change you and therefore
effect pd-1 PDL ionization so that's
also the message we would like to
developer is not is rather quality of
the PDL one maybe more important than
the quantity of the PDA or one so
therefore as a basically scientist is
important to really understand what the
guy can structure and how those guy can
charge will happen that way through
genomic instability and cause certain
die castration moiety pattern on the PDL
1 and that contribute to immuno
suppression that's a very difficult
question and that we would like to
further pursue thank you okay so the
last one from this person is what do you
think about a combination a radiotherapy
and PDL one antibody to kill cancer
cells I think those has been approved
some of the literature I remember
already prefer some of the concept as a
radiotherapy will create more newer
indigene genomic instability and then
have more new entity and therefore
cancer cell has more immune response to
it will attract in a way into a more
t-cell into the tumor micro area so we
said it's that we predict that a PDA or
one response will be much higher
the presents are radiotherapy I think in
fact that nd me already publish your
paper in the still I've seen 2016 also
talked about they had multiple paper Oh
deal with radiotherapy plus entire city
over or you know Authority
I think they these are very similar the
rushing so if you are increased on that
I just you to maybe read more of the
data and gaming's paper and if you still
have crushing can not find a paper feel
free to contact us we are happy to share
the knowledge and in the thank you for
watching I would like to once again
thank dr. Lee for his presentation do
you have any final comments yes thank
you for having me to have this
opportunity to present our recent work
and we are very excited that this is a
simple straightforward finding and we
would like to develop we would like to
collaborate so whoever in the audience
if you know the counter will be like
question you have any suggestions please
contact us and we are waiting and happy
to share we aging or discuss the science
or in a possible future if we can create
collaboration or brainstorm to each
other and benefit others project that
will be tremendous so again thank you
and I really appreciate this event can i
for one more question at you um we're
going to close out how about
glycosylated EGFR suspect let's see let
me
how about glycosylated EGFR effect PDL
one expression in triple negative breast
cancer so let's see to to phrase it how
how does glycosylated EGFR affect PDL
one expression in triple negative breast
cancer
so the question is how does the
calculator EGFR hmm yes got EGFR also
gay Calcutta days and it's not our sofa
we haven't come to life stage to study
the III a pocket a sedation we know when
we treat with to minimizing the
expression of EGFR we are reduced now we
have not looked into to compare and
which is a good question I mean that's a
very beneficial to our research it that
is to compare the response of the guy
cos theta4 of EGFR and nongak a severe
form of EGFR in the presence of EGF I
think that's a really good question and
right now we don't know because that's
involving Ligon and the receptor
interaction whether the guy can
structure of the EGFR had anything to do
with the item Association which is you
know how we have to test so to answer
this question quickly as I mentioned
earlier we do test the different
receptor and like compare in 22 case so
some guy castration effector for import
interaction and some case
characterization is not involved
so for each UF and EGFR whether the guy
can charge of the EGFR if you're finding
we had no idea thank you thank you again
dr. Lee and I'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their very interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor as in bioscience for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the C button at the bottom left
corner and follow the process to receive
your credits this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through March 7th 2018
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that an email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
event until next time goodbye